boy has it been a rough week for Silicon
Valley Twitter in hot water for shadow
banning conservatives something they had
to reluctantly admit and today their
stock is down over 20% Facebook stock
has cratered after they missed their
earnings estimates for the first time in
three years and to make matters worse
the social media giant is now accused of
banning this ad from a Florida
Republican because of the second
amendment message watch
I'm Matt Caldwell I like guns
I love the Second Amendment and I
support our president that's why I'm
endorsed by the NRA
I'm Matt Caldwell and that's all there
is to it I like that ad here to respond
this is the candidate himself state Rep
Matt Caldwell who is running as a
candidate for the Commissioner of
Agriculture
all right representative Caldwell how
did you find out this was you know
banned on Facebook yeah absolutely Laura
we have been obviously running statewide
for over a year now and running multiple
ads every single day just
run-of-the-mill stuff hey like this like
that we go and post this mom and apple
pie pro-second amendment pro president
Trump Pro our NRA endorsement ad and it
gets flagged immediately and so we do
what it tells you to hey appeal it let
us know why you don't think it should be
flagged and of course we wait and we
wait and we wait no response here we are
five weeks out from our primary two
million voters in Florida we have to
talk to and we're losing time while they
I don't know review it it gets lost in
the black hole and so we called them out
in the media put out a press release and
said that we'd been blocked from talking
about this straightforward message that
I've been sharing across the state for
the last year and a half and until we
called them out for it they didn't take
any action of course once we did that
the bad publicity they called us up
immediately apologized authorized it but
really it's just that the precedent you
know you go look through Facebook's
policies and automatically anything that
deals with guns or ammunition it gets
flagged and you know I've running for
office so I've got a platform they paid
attention to me but what about private
citizens
the average person that's trying to use
this platform to talk about the things
they believe in the things they want to
share with the public where did they put
the same they don't have the same
opportunity that you have certainly as
you said the platform and it makes you
wonder how often this happens in the
course of a day and there's a lot of
there's a lot of stuff you know on these
social media platforms that most people
find objectionable but it doesn't get
flagged and whether it's nudity semi
nudity or violence from film clips or so
how do you start making that judgment I
mean this is where I do kind of prefer
the free market unless it's someone
being mutilated or you know or something
it's really vile and incitement of
violence but thus far there is no other
problem with Facebook today right well
no so they're running our ads now and
have told us we shouldn't have any more
problems but again it just shows you
where their mindset is at you know why
are guns
automatically what why are they
automatically flagged but you've got
things like abortion and you can
abortion ad that would be totally
presentative called well we're out of
time but we're gonna keep an eye on this
issue because I have a feeling this
isn't the last time we're gonna be
dealing with this